forensic experts will try to identify
the presumed remains of dozens of
Americans killed in the Korean War
fifty-five flag covered caskets were met
by Vice President pence and military
honor guards yesterday when they arrived
at a military base in Hawaii North
Korea's leader promised to their return
at his June summit with President Trump
the President thanked North Korean
leader Kim jong-un on Twitter for
sending the remains
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn shows us what their return
means for the families after more than
60 years service members presumed killed
in the Korean War arrived on US soil
Wednesday their flag draped casket
slowly filling a military hangar in
Honolulu today begins a new season of
hope for the families of our missing
fallen hope that after so many years of
questions these families will have
closure
many of these photos we actually got
from the families back in March we spoke
with the government agency that accounts
for Americans lost in conflict in this
room and along this table you can see
some of the artifacts that the PIO wmia
accounting agency laboratory have
collected items that soldiers sailors
Marines Airmen would have carried with
them into battle through lab analysis of
artifacts bones and DNA the agency works
to identify the soldiers and bring their
families closure when these guys went
missing it like created a big hole in
their life what we're trying to do is
fill that hole as much as we can but the
lab now faces a challenge there was only
one dog tag amid the 55 sets of remains
and when North Korea has returned
remains in decades past the bones of
different people have reportedly been
combined together or mixed with animal
remains initial reports say these new
remains appear to be in a similar state
of disarray meaning the identifying
process could take years
still many believe getting these
servicemembers back on US soil brings
them one step closer to their loved ones
some have called the Korean War the
Forgotten War but today we prove these
heroes were never forgotten for CBS this
morning
vladimir duthiers los angeles ving story